everything I just said sounds
inspirational it's actually practical
it's not rah-rah [ __ ] like you can do it
it's how are you choosing to look at
your life and then if you practically
realize opportunity and be grateful for
whatever the [ __ ] you have because
somebody's always got it worse well then
it could starts getting interesting
you got your prospective DJ will such a
pleasure pleasure it's a real pleasure
it's ridiculous these are insta-famous
it's a real pleasure nice to meet you
hello Natasha how are you good
what's good everyone thank you so much I
am almost answering the questions that
people ask well sometimes it's in cotton
you know what I like about it still to
your point I'm so consistent sometimes
people make fun of me of like you say
the same [ __ ] I'm like that's the
[ __ ] point like people when they
leave comments or say to me like you say
the same [ __ ] think they're dissing me
I'm like [ __ ] that's the point
and and then but where it's nuanced and
what's why it's nice to meet people is
sometimes it can be subtly nuanced
everybody's question comes from a
slightly different point the big part of
what I'm trying to figure out what to do
is like I back to what I was just saying
there are 1327 things that are the
things then it's like what's up in your
life somebody has a sick mother
somebody's trying to [ __ ] rule the
world they don't care about money they
want [ __ ] Fame some people want fame
somewhat legacy some just want their kid
to be proud of them cuz they're not
proud of their dad or mom like there's
so much [ __ ] underneath it but the
foundation the [ __ ] I'm spinning it's
[ __ ] real and then and then the other
thing that you don't know when you're 15
and a [ __ ] knucklehead is life is
long thank God obviously tragically
sometimes no but like there's a very
high chance that the four busts are
gonna live to 50 years each longer
there's a lot to do we grew we were
parented and Grandpere did by people who
didn't live to a hundred but we are so
that's the [ __ ] I'm trying to get people
to think about how old are you right so
like when we were [ __ ] 1843 seem like
a thousand
but now we're like I don't know like I'm
40 foot like I feel like I got my whole
life in front of me yeah I think we've
been through some [ __ ] but like there's
a lot to do for me I started feeling
last couple years like damn
is to sit and then you know what ends up
happening in your game is when you're in
something that has young youth culture
in it you see somebody doing something
special that you're proud of for them or
happy for them or envious of them and
they're 19 you're like damn my whole
thing is like don't look at them look at
the other 4 billion people that are 80
doing [ __ ] everyone's like McGary look
at Mark Zuckerberg 25 or look at [ __ ]
chance the rapper he already did I'm
like what about the [ __ ] brilliant
[ __ ] people that are 80 doing [ __ ]
and still haven't broke through why are
you looking at the point oo-oo-oo-oo 1%
to judge your happiness why don't we
look at the [ __ ] masses right I sit
in this room what us being in America
we're ready winning perspective and once
you see gratitude an opportunity life is
fun when you think something's
suppressing you it's easier for you to
feel suppress minority all that I get it
that's true that's actually true but
once you get into what am I gonna look
at a lot of things are true what was
true for me as I spent the first 20
years building my parents business for
them that was my truth like lots of
things are true
the colbys life was good and then it had
a tragic end like like there's a lot of
choice but people just you get to decide
if you're gonna dwell and play prevent
defense or if you're gonna see
opportunity and be grateful and go on
offense that's what I'm trying to get
people through I could sit with anybody
show me the richest white male in
America and he'll cry about some [ __ ]
like his mom was horrible you know what
I mean
like you pick yeah show me and then and
that everybody knows somebody who's got
all sorts of [ __ ] up situations and
they're happy
that's called perspective I know
everybody can talk about somebody who's
happier than them that has it way worse
and sadder than them that has it way
better right
and if that's true which it is for
everybody if you think then that becomes
the actual game that's what I think
about and that's what I'm trying to be
popular and that's why I think it's
making an impact because it leads to a
nice place you know yeah because ma you
know I come from a place that's more
zero and so it and and the way I talk to
people in that spot is not looking down
at them and it's not even trying to
inspire them it's just real everything I
just said sounds inspirational it's
actually practical it's not rah-rah [ __ ]
like you can do it it's how are you
choosing to look at your life and then
if you practically realize opportunity
and be grateful for whatever the [ __ ]
you have because somebody's always got
it worse well then it could starts
getting interesting other than the money
was driving you to the best part is the
money is not driving me at all I've seen
ya like but I could be really really
wealthy if that was my game I like the
legacy I like the Amrish I like these
moments I like people I really like
people yeah I got really lucky that
social media came along where people
interaction went to scale because the
way people the way people look at me now
it's just like the way that they looked
at me when I was a kid and my crew I was
the nice person I was the person up in
height like my high school friends
popping out they're like actually this
makes sense
you gave up popularity cuz you could
have had it cuz every poplar kid liked
you because you want to be friends with
everybody and that cost you in high
school but that's who you actually are
the sports car Flex wasn't to say look
at me I put 50 into LeBron now it's
200,000 that video was [ __ ] I
just told you nine months ago to do this
you could have done it too with one
LeBron guess what because I was there
when you only have when you not only
when you have a thousand dollars to
spend on something and it becomes worth
four thousand and you could buy it on
eBay and sell it in eBay between April
and February that [ __ ] matters yeah
right I think all of us can remember
when $1,000 was a big [ __ ] deal and
the thought of making a good decision
doing something and five months later
you have four thousand that [ __ ]
resonates to all of us I remember that
day like yesterday we're [ __ ] taking
a thousand to four thousand but what do
people do they go to a casino but what
do people do they bet but one of people
they do dumb [ __ ] and I'm saying it's
that same hustles out here you know
basketball players good so it's kind of
it's an interesting it's why I'm
confusing cuz when I do it right like I
understand how it can be seen I'm just
not worried about the judgment for every
person at the end be like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] who has $50,000 to buy
sport cars and like [ __ ] you
didn't hear what I said
this wasn't for you you've decided to
look at the perspective of coming up
with excuses why you're not winning
[ __ ] I had nothing
there's a lot of people out there do
have $1,000 who are trying to get go in
how do I the system [ __ ] me no it
doesn't you know the bronze the best you
know sports cars to come in I'm giving
it to you for free because you're
following me on social media going by
the [ __ ] LeBron you can have 4,000
now by the way it's going to 10,000
right I see straight up I'm telling you
right to your face right now if you have
$40,000 you can go on eBay by LeBron
it's 4,000 and 6,000 in July when
they're in the finals something like I
don't care about 2000 bucks I'm like by
eighty of them that's 160 thousand bucks
so what I'm trying to do in a lot of
different ways is trying to teach but
I'm doing it from an angle where some
people really he'll hear me and that's
why they're growing and some people
don't like it because they don't want to
do it I'm put pressure I'm putting the
pressure time token I'm poking my cool
you're more than welcome to complain
nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody cares man and
like what I took what I talked to
African American I wish I wish I wish
100 percent of every white person in
America knew what it was like to get
pulled over 13 times in a year
it's just something they'll never know
all my friends in college were black so
I but I still wasn't me I was in it I
was in I did get pulled over all those
times because I was in the car but even
though I knew it you don't know it until
you're in it and you still can't fully
feel like when you're not it right but
it'd be nice to even know how true it is
that's what everything is so that's the
example of race issues then there's the
example of opportunity I wish everybody
knew that had 100 bucks right now that
if they went garage saling to Goodwill
and the dollar store and worked instead
of crying about it
and six months later had 2000 I wish
they could taste it cuz pride is a lot
of times disguising insecurity capsuleer
right you're worried about somebody
seeing you go to the dollar store and
you're not looking they'd rather spend
800 bucks they don't have on some
Weatherspoon's then spend a hundred
bucks to go to dollar store buy 40 or 50
of these things and everyone's laughing
at them
I just didn't give a [ __ ] the ability
not give a [ __ ] of course that's it
that's why if you look Russian
immigrants and African Americans are
very simply flex for perception not
truth that's real that's why do it now
Dawes and I do it now and here's what
happens in the comments on YouTube I go
and garage and I'll do it in a couple of
months when it warms up and the calm and
I'll show I'm trying to teach people so
when somebody's like 6 bucks I'm like 3
bucks and the comments if your
perspective is complaining and shit's
[ __ ] up like [ __ ] this guy
you're a [ __ ] millionaire the [ __ ]
are you ripping these people off right
on the flip side I'm getting the DMS in
the comments from people like you taught
me
now I do this now I quit this [ __ ]
job got a different job because I'm
making enough on my side also of garage
saling mom happy now that's that I need
to be able to deal with the judgment of
somebody calling me a millionaire
ripping off poor people that hurts
somebody Ted I didn't steal it I went to
a garage sale they wanted six bucks I
offered him three bucks they were pumped
they're pumped
they were happy they were happy they
were they were I'm there I know they
were thrilled that's garbage their
mother throw that out
they were pumped but no cynicism the kid
laying in YouTube watched that YouTube
that he watching me who doesn't want to
work oh I see how he got ahead he took
advantage of people
uh-uh you have an excuse to not work my
first my first bro bro the amount of
people that hit me up my friends friends
are like yo you can't do this you look
stupid and literally on that first day I
did that first I think I did I'm
Instagram stories before I did a YouTube
video an idea my friends back I was like
you don't know me you think you know me
you know me now
this is Who I am I'm dirt dirt you think
on penthouse I'm dirt dirt and that's
and that's right and that's why I think
I resonate in certain pockets whether
it's the culture you know because I'm
dirt I definitely understand it I lived
it that's what I was in it
they donors say that I'm going to
Chicago this weekend and I'm gonna win
the spades tournament but I know but I
know and that's and that's what people
said every time something comes out that
gives people a little bit of perspective
it's the same old thing they're like oh
now I get it
I'm dirt the only thing is to find
happiness on your terms and then
reinforce it so much that you can't even
hear people's opinions on what you
should be doing to be happy like I did
it for so long like this is perfect when
this is your report like this is the
[ __ ] right like again you start hitting
the scene and everybody sees you but if
people knew that I was do literally this
is my entire high school my class rank
was 243 out of 254 I was literally the
11th worst student in my entire grade
I'm dirt this whole system told me I was
a loser
that I would never amount to nothing
we're in the same age group there was no
entrepreneurship when were coming up
there's hustle for you guys but like in
my world there wasn't entrepreneur no
one ever got a thing you weren't
starting a company go to college right
how many times do we hear that go to
college as if it was the only [ __ ]
path but for me why I'm at this place of
this young of an age is back then I knew
I'm like cool you keep telling me but
I'm in my own head I know exactly what
I'm doing I'm gonna be nice to the Nerds
cuz they're humans I'm gonna sell
baseball cards in the lunchroom while
you all laugh at me cuz I don't give a
[ __ ] what you think I don't need your
[ __ ] confirmation affirmation or
cosign in my head at 12 I'm like you're
gonna want my cosign and now I'm right
practice that practice and then also
like another thing that I'm really
trying to talk to people about is like
everybody else sucks to like one thing
that really worked for me and I'm
starting to talk about it's like when I
would feel bad I'm like like if I never
envied anybody because I would look at
somebody no matter what they were
somebody's dunking and I'm like barely
got my jump shot down I'm like yeah but
they suck it they're not nice or like
like you know like to me it's like why
are you being yourself up and putting
somebody else on a pedestal
they got [ __ ] shortcomings too right
like they're just human and then what
that does is a weird thing then you
start celebrating people instead of end
being them for second in non-coated that
seems like you're hating right so it's a
difference we can say like you know nice
but then here's the best books you'll
preach to this room every culture is
same that's the slang term we use in
that culture like my grandma uses that
term too she was a white russian woman
she had a turn for it jealousy you know
to me you know in Russian and Yiddish
she's like every culture has got the
same [ __ ] they just use different words
it's all the same [ __ ] it's all the same
[ __ ] just different words you just say
it better that's why I became the lay of
the land honestly on some real [ __ ] you
know what I mean like hip-hop is rock
and roll
those were gutter kids that were anti
the establishment right and you can
already see it right now with sexual
preferences
transgender other things that's gonna be
the next culture it's been written in 30
years right it's been written because
now there's somebody's more suppressed
than you that's all that happens it's
always the same kids from the dirt
always win in the end if they can keep
their mind right most can't and they
feel the pressure and they break but the
small percentage that realizes it's a
strength not a weakness yeah that's why
when I make content people are confused
I'm like talking about rich kids and I'm
like you don't get it they've been told
they can't win so they've already lost
their parents are taking care of
everything
every time I put out that content the
whole supress comes at me like [ __ ] you
I'd rather cry in a Mercedes I'm like
you don't get it it's cuz you write just
like your white friends saying I get it
the contraband right well guess what if
you're not a rich kid you don't get it
either I understand you want the
Mercedes let me tell you about the
[ __ ] deep pain that's going on when
your parents in the world and no matter
what you accomplish everyone's gonna say
it was your daddy's money you lost when
you start at zero or suppress at least
you have a chance to climb out and then
be on a hurry you have a hope you can be
on a pedestal
you're admired from coming from it when
you're the other way you lost before you
start there's nothing you can do and
they really break right I'm talking
suicide right like right mental health
it's so funny and I gotta run so much
about white privilege I think about it a
lot obviously cuz I care about these
cultures how they mix when we get to
mental health privilege that's gonna be
the biggest conversation if you are
privileged enough to have self esteem
through chemicals and parenting you've
won
and that's what I'm trying to do for my
audience I'm trying to be the gap of
building up their self-esteem but first
you have to be not entitled and stop
complaining
because nobody's listening but another
[ __ ] loser the only person that
listens if somebody complain
somebody else that complains and you get
into what's right and you get into one
big dinner of do well fast and everybody
leaves unhappy like as if anything and
what I nobody seems [ __ ] about it that
was fun
[Music]